when i decided to do dune i wanted
really to create a new soundscape and i
was in need of a composer
i asked ann zimmer if he knew june the
book and ant answered was that it was
probably one of his favorite book of all
time and it was one of his biggest
dreams to score june so his answer was a
big yes
it was always more about the
conversation because i knew the book so
well he knew the book so well we knew
our subject so now it was figuring out
how we were going to interpret something
that we truly loved and admired
and denis worked very closely together
part of what i love about the score is
how unfamiliar it is it's incredibly
exotic it's emotional it's intense it is
wholly original and very specific to the
film
we're telling a story in
multi-dimensional
ways and we're using voices and a
language that you don't understand and
at the same time somehow you understand
it emotionally
he did tons of experience he created
even instruments he kept saying to me
that music is not from our world it
needs to come from another time another
planet those sounds cannot be have been
heard before
i then ended up you know spending
forever making sounds making instruments
getting people to
learn how to play instruments in a
different way
the one thing that we felt would be true
through any culture would be the voice
so the score is based on mainly female
voices and then we developed our own
language
he had recordings being made all around
the world
for months and you could tell his team
were just living that extreme studio
town lifestyle editing together
thousands of samples and recordings if
you surround yourself with incredibly
brave reckless and talented people
they'll lead you into new directions
automatically i always know we're on the
right path when somebody goes this might
be the worst idea you've ever heard
and spent months defining sounds
creating new sounds searching pushing
pushing the envelope to be reflected and
doing tons of experiments and crazy
experiments with crazy instruments
it's quite a privilege for me to work
with such an artist one of the most
inspiring and powerful artistic
encounter in my life is the one with
anzanmir so to have the chance to work
with him on june is like one of the big
privilege of my life
i want the audience to come with us on
this journey to this planet and to this
world which seems huge and vast
unfathomable and then at the same time
realize that it's all about the smallest
and tiniest emotion
just like the desert is made up of
grains of sand and the music is just
made up of grains of notes
so rather than it being a massive
blanket of sound this is different
this is moving emotion this is saying a
lot but i think it's one of the best
scores that hans has ever written it
really kind of touches you inside it
makes you feel something
[Music]
[Music]
you